ich habe drauf los und es ist möglich
[Musik]
umbringen
tausende schaulustige drängen sich vor
dem justizpalast in münchen
alle wollen einen blick auf die frau
werfen die gerade des mordes an dem
millionenschweren arzt dr otto braun und
dessen geliebter schuldig gesprochen
wurde
vera brühne ist das erste it girl ihrer
zeit in der münchner schickeria der
biederen 60er jahre zu hause hier werden
zahlreiche affären nachgesagt auch mit
dem mordopfer
als das urteil fällt bebt ganz
deutschland die lebedame beherrscht
schlagzeile aber war sie es wirklich
inzwischen gibt es zweifel an ihrer
schuld bild recherchierte in geheimen
bnd und gerichtsakten sprach exklusiv
mit ihrem adoptivsohn es geht um
waffenhandel
im dienst sind nun mal dafür
bekannt durchaus auch
mordet so verüben schlampige
ermittlungen
es gab keine anständige spurensicherung
bei den leichen und den kampf um die
wahrheit
[Musik]
es ist gründonnerstag der vierzehnte
april 1960 vera brühne verlässt gegen
späten nachmittag ihre wohnung in der
kaulbachstraße 40 im münchner
szeneviertel schwabing mit ihrem
bekannten johann iv erbach fährt sie
richtung starnberger see ihr ziel die
villa von dr otto braun in pöcking iv
erbach und grüne parken unweit der villa
steigen gemeinsam aus erbach klingelte
friede clou ist allein vera brühne
stellt ihren begleiter vor feuerbach
lockt die geliebte des arztes in den
keller und schießt die 49 jährige
elfriede klo stirbt an einem
genickschuss
dann wartet der mörder bis dr brown
gegen 19.25 nach hause kommt er schießt
dem arzt in den mund und in die schläfe
dann verlässt verwahrt das haus
ich möchte dass die schmach von meiner
mutter genommen wird meine mutter ist
keine frau die aus habgier jemanden zu
morden angestiftet hat vera brühne
vorderen oder das größte justizopfer
ihrer zeit